the challenge should be to try and play
as diverse characters as possible it
would get boring for the audience and
for the actor if you played characters
that were similar all the time what I
want is to work with people with strong
visions they do this crazy thing now for
more from Boys & Girls II this kind of
chemistry testing with like that's the
most absurd thing in the world to me I
don't know sometimes you feel like a
total waste of space ready when you look
at people with proper jobs and then
you're like what am i doing hello bleep
nation its Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in people more than they
believe in themselves and my sincere
hope is that if you see in yourself what
I see in you you'll be able to change
the planet so to help you on your
journey today we're gonna learn from
actor Cillian Murphy and my take on its
top ten rules success rule number seven
is my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one that you guys like the
best also as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
I put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired by it as well and if you
leave it within the first couple hours
of this video going live you have a
chance to win one of two daily prizes
the challenge should be to try and play
as diverse characters as possible it
would get boring for the audience and
for the actor if you played characters
that were similar all the time one one
hop two hop one two three
[Music]
four actors you know we're supposed to
be able to and have a different
characters that's kind of the searcher
hop that's for acting should be ensuring
the big action flick in it
I'm Killian Murphy and I'm an actor I
suppose Oh Killian reverser heard you
say that one of your happiest places is
on set when you hear the word action
yeah I mean if I'm in the film ah yeah
otherwise it's just awkward everyone
involved isn't happy now
yeah well it is it's that thing of where
you know that's the kind of the moments
you've been looking forward to building
up towards and and it is it is true to
say that time kind of slows down and you
stop sensing things in a kind of a
normal way and and we I love it that
means my favorite part of the whole the
whole thing and it's it's the thing you
kind of live for anything what's the
hardest scene or moment for you as an
actor this season on the show I mean the
whole thing is is challenging due to the
the nature of the schedule and the lay
you know it's a very talky show there's
a lot of dialogue honest a lot of big
scenes for Tommy and he's kind of you
know this season particularly there was
a lot of trauma that he ain't can't
enjoy I don't know man I love doing it I
love all the big I love the big scenes I
love working with Helen McCrory I love
working with Paul Anderson I love
working with Tom Hardy you know l III
relish those big scenes those
confrontational scenes they're very very
satisfying for an actor when you get
that caliber of actor acting up you know
so they're never there's there's nothing
that you always go home for work going
wow I went to work today you know so
this would be I'm trying to take now
it's just like your third or fourth film
Chris run off well people are saying
fifth but you know I only talked about
from the Batman a little bit yeah what
you want as a as a character I certainly
what I want is to work with people with
strong visions you know and you can't
find anybody with the stronger vision
than Christopher Nolan you know I mean
he's written produced and directed this
you know paying and
it's kind of kind of phenomenal and you
know it is still collaborative like we
spent a lot of time on the phone talking
about this character and talking about
how to pitch it and and he just kind of
left me off to go and do my research and
they bring my research to him and say
look I've thought this this and this
might be appropriate so what do you
think so yeah I mean your there is
absolutely scope to collaborate but you
want to work with someone who is that
told idea yeah or it just has I mean he
like he knows exactly every frame of the
film as he as he shooting it you know
which is so comforting him it's a real
privilege to work with him every time I
mean there's no argument that he's had
one of the greatest directors around at
the moment I think everyone accepts that
so as an actor selfishly you want to
work with the best people and he's
definitely one of those and but every
every every relationship between a
director and an actor should be
collaborative I mean II you know they're
the boss and they're the leader but you
know it has to be an exchange of ideas
always I just was realizing that I was I
was really into performing you know and
I wasn't quite sure I just live
performance I was I really like to play
the guitar and sing and I really liked
acting on stage this director of a
theater company came in and worked with
us for of course a few months and I
loved it and I kind of I thought he was
just the coolest guy ever I just
developed a huge man crush on him and
then I'd see him out in Cork drinking
like in pubs and things and I got to
give me an audition for a play for our
plates and he gave me an audition and it
was a furnace play called disco pigs and
they became quite successful
we made the play and I made a film the
man and woman know really bad bears no
more that kind of changed everything
really I had never ever envisaged ever
being in a film or being on television I
think that I was I wanted to be a
theatre actor that's what I saw
happening you know when I decided to go
for it I moved to London and started to
get slightly bigger parts I did this
film called 28 days later
people saw that fit I'm gonna give
thought in America and that definitely
was a marker as well because you know I
was working with Danny Boyle and it was
the lead part Oh shouldn't don't know I
was really aware of the script being
fantastic and Danny being Danny and I
really really worked at the auditions I
did like five auditions and auditioning
is a terrible terrible experience you
know because you know you're not giving
a performance it's a different skill
what not one that I'm very good at or
was very good at Danny saw something and
took a chance and that is a film are
very proud of and for some reason it
resonated with people and people went to
see us so that's where people you know
began to attempt to pronounce my name in
attempting ever since and you're both
actors who tends to start in more
dramatic roles and comedic ones is that
a conscious decision as an actor or is
it literally the scripts are come in the
ones that you like are the ones with
those roles yes actually it tends to be
that I mean I love love watching
comedies or whatever but the films that
I really really the ones that are close
to my heart I guess her that and the
dramatic ones you know on the the pieces
of it generally not just films like
pieces of art and literature and
everything they tend to be the ones I
think where the stakes are raised and to
me that is drama yeah the greater the
stakes the greater the drama and that to
me is more compelling to watch and
that's I guess the sort of material that
I'm drawn to it's always a gamble a
casting thing you know and did they in
fact they do this crazy thing now for
more from boys and girls it's kind of
chemistry Testament like that's the most
absurd thing in the world to me how
could you manufacture that it's it's
some weird outcome you can't it's just
there it isn't there and we just you
know it was the same for me we went for
dinner happened that I myself my wife
were obsessed with the fall at the time
like you know I did such an incredible
job and I loved that show and then we
just met and and and it just seemed to
work and it's a similar sense of humor
and a similar approach to work as Jamie
said and you know I forgot I mean I
forgot how how intense that film is and
we forgot like its it doesn't really let
up but - so we have do we have - the
three of us I think together we managed
to make the atmosphere on set
you know quite quite an enjoyable one
despite everything else and anything
again it's - Sean Testament you know
that that's the wrong word but Sean
should take the credit for the fact you
know there was families around and it
was a very very lovely environment to
work in and then we we had fun and I
think you have to do you're lucky to be
working or looking to be working on such
a good project and you you know you
can't go around all sort of sad and
intense you know it's got it you've got
it and get through the day I know
sometimes you feel like a total waste of
space really when you look at people
with proper jobs and then you okay one
of my doom flouncing around putting on
voice isn't dressing up but people need
to go to the pictures and people need
some sort of escape artists don't let
people down like politicians let people
down bankers let people down the quality
the work might fluctuate but they keep
making it we keep trying and I keep
giving some sort of succor I think you
know
overpaid and there's a huge amount of
stupidity and hot air that that
surrounds it all and a lot of that I
don't subscribe to but I think sometimes
the film can change someone's life if
you can do that through a piece of art
and that's feel like you're up giving
something up or in fact what I think you
always you have to learn from each job
you do isn't actually constantly
learning and it's an ongoing learning
process really but this is unique for me
certainly in to develop a character over
a long period of time and so draw with
the character I've never done that
before
and I supposed to have the confidence in
going that once we established it and
people you know I'm invested in it to a
degree then you can be brave
I suppose it's that I've tried to take
that from Anna's lesson that you can
actually be brave of the character and
take it places that you might not have
necessarily thought of at the beginning
there's such an amount of resources out
there for an actor you know nowadays too
you can research everything and and I
think that is your duty to do that but
again you know I always went over every
role I try to do as much research as
possible to have it all available and
once you've done that kind of leave it
behind because you have to focus on the
truth of the character and you have to
make the character as believable as
possible in terms of the research so I
mean were there any and we're there any
performances that you drew upon I mean
was there any kind of film or no theatre
or play or anything like that that
you've kind of watched or drew upon to
give you a sense of the character no I
don't really go to other performances
for inspiration really I did a lot of
research kind of about show soldiers
that had shell-shocked didn't that was
kind of what sort of informed mostly
mmm-hmm on that I mean what did you do I
mean did you meet with you know PTSD
serve I reserve now I didn't I mean I
wanted to try to sort of because there's
a lot about it nowadays ask like
they didn't have a clue than me you know
how to treat it and didn't in the
symptoms were so kind of bizarre like I
read about this one soldier who who
actually went blind for no physiological
reason other than he was the trauma made
an align so that that was the power of
what they had seen so they were kind of
you you kind of have to interpret it as
sensitively and as kind of I don't know
as carefully as he can
it's very clear that this is a damaged
guy who's sort of violence is a form of
expression for him and that's a big
distance to travel or for me as well to
get to that you know and he's the most
sort of capable person I've ever played
and I think that's not me either how
much did you pay for the suit you will
be wearing oh I don't pay for suits my
suits and on the house or the house
burns down
you're inhabiting this character all the
time in effectiveness of a subliminal
way I think it affects you sort of by
osmosis but I'm not very aware of it
it's only people that are around you
that are more aware of it like my wife
will be aware of when I playing him
I think but I'll come back no she's in
charge of of course it has to
concentrate a lot any talks a lot it's
most a lot of [ __ ] and it's currently
fighting so he's exhausting
in time
I thought it was a terrible idea at the
beginning to put content using on a
period show I thought it was silly but
then it just seemed to work because them
that the artists that they chose were
he's kind of outlaw you know artists and
then that seemed to work for me was huge
that like Nick Cave had to watch it and
get say yeah I'll give you my music for
it so the faculty actually watched this
video thank you guys so much for
watching I made this video because
George Sid asked me to if there's
someone you like me to profile in their
future top ten please check out the link
down in the description below and you
can cast your vote on who we should do
next I also want to give a quick shout
out to Pedro Cologne Pedro thank you so
much for picking up the audio version of
my book your one word you said that you
didn't expect it to be such an amazing
book so I'm glad we were able to over
deliver on those expectations but I
really appreciate you sharing it on
Twitter with your audience as well it
really means a lot to me and I'm glad
you enjoyed the book thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope we can - need to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon